Bonjour.
Vous qui regardez cette vidéo, il y a fort
à parier que vous ne connaissez personne
dans votre entourage qui soit devenu moine.
Les monastères ne font plus partie de notre
décor que pour les ruines ou bâtiments reconvertis
qu'on en conserve: depuis la réforme luthérienne
en Europe centrale puis la Révolution française
chez nous, l'importance des moines a décliné
pour se réduire à quelques monastères reculés
et à la mémoire, faible, d'une culture monastique.
Genre le chaussée aux moines.
C'est pas un sponsor.
Pourtant si on remonte dans le temps comme
on sait si bien le faire, on trouve une institution
organisée et très importante dans l'Europe
médiévale.
-Un truc de chrétiens? Ça ne prendra jamais.
-Oui, ben Lucretia, tu es clairement hors
sujet comme toujours mais du côté d'Aliénor...
-Alors il y a tonton Hubert qui est entré
dans les ordres, et puis mes cousins ont fait
don de leur petit dernier, et grand-mère
Marguerite est devenue moniale à la fin de
sa vie, et...
-Voilà.
Une institution super importante, on vous
dit.
Au commencement, y'avait pas de moines, forcément.
La vie monastique n'est pas décrite dans
les textes saints, on y parle par contre de
pratiquer l'ascèse, c'est à dire la recherche
d'une perfection spirituelle, mais ça passe
plutôt par la charité.
Par contre à partir du IVe siècle, certains
chrétiens d'Egypte se disent que ça serait
pas mal pour renforcer leur croyance de partir
dans le désert, de fuir la société, en
s'inspirant de Jésus qui a vécu 40 jours
dans le désert.
-Ils décident de partir seuls et ça tombe
bien parce que moine vient de monos qui veut
dire seul.
-L'idée est de s'isoler, d'abandonner les
tentations matérielles, la culture profane,
et de ne plus faire rien d'autre que lire
les textes sacrés.
Et prier.
Manger, des fois.
-L'autre idée des chrétiens de l'époque
est que puisqu'on ne peut plus mourir pour
Dieu, ce qui était la spécialité de mon
temps, il est trop facile d'être chrétien
alors disparaître du monde, c'est plutôt
osé.
-On a donc les premiers ermites, qu'on surnomme
les Pères du désert, comme par exemple saint
Antoine, saint Pacôme...
Mais très vite des groupes se forment autour
d'eux: on passe de l'érémitisme, vivre
sa religion seul dans son coin, au cénobitisme:
vivre sa religion en communauté.
Pas trop grande.
Cénobite.
Car vivre en communauté n'est pas forcément
incompatible avec la recherche de solitude
des moines: vivre seul veut aussi dire vivre
séparé du reste des hommes, de la société,
des normes qui imposeraient normalement de
travailler et de se marier...
Donc le cénobitisme devient vite très populaire
parmi les ermites.
On retrouve d'ailleurs cette forme de vie
avant l'apparition du christianisme, parmi
les pythagoriciens, les bouddhistes ou les
juifs Thérapeutes et non ce ne sont pas des
juifs qui écoutent vos problèmes mais on
n'a pas le temps de s'attarder sur eux.
Le premier à fonder une communauté est Saint
Pacôme, et très vite quand il y a une communauté
un chef s'impose.
On lui donne le nom d'Abba, parce que c'était
une reine de la danse.
Et surtout parce que abba veut dire père
en grec, ce qui donne ensuite le nom d'abbé!
A la fin du IVe siècle il existe donc plusieurs
petites communautés en Egypte, en Palestine,
en Asie Mineure...
-Dans la 2e moitié du IVe siècle la vie
du premier ermite, saint Antoine, est écrite
et diffusée en Occident, ce qui donne l'idée
à des occidentaux de faire pareil.
Imitateurs.
-Il y a aussi des voyageurs qui reviennent
d'Orient et qui racontent la cuisine locale,
l'hébergement pas terrible, et surtout ces
gars qui vivent en communauté pour la religion
mais sans faire partie de l’Église, trop
bizarres.
-On voit alors en Occident des ermites s'installer
à la campagne, dans les forêts, les îles...
Forcément, c'est assez difficile de transposer
la vie dans le désert en Europe à moins
de se poser sur la dune du Pilat.
En Europe il fait plus froid, plus humide,
alors il faut s'adapter.
Du coup dans les vies d'ermites qui sont écrites
par la suite, on met plutôt l'accent sur
le territoire sauvage qui est le vrai lieu
d'exercice spirituel et d'épreuve pour les
moines.
L'un des premiers ermites de nos régions
est Saint-Martin de Tours, qui commence sa
vie ermite et termine par fonder des monastères,
suivant ainsi la carrière type de tout bon
religieux.
-Et aussi évêque.
Et saint.
Beau parcours.
On a peu de traces des vrais ermites parce
que beaucoup de biographies de saints de l'époque
carolingienne ne sont pas hyper fiables, et
aussi parce que l'archéologie est pas hyper
précise pour retrouver des cabanes isolées
vieilles de 1500 ans.
Grâce aux lieux d'ermitage attestés, environ
4000 entre le IVe et le XVIIIe siècle, on
sait que l'ermite sauvage pouvait surtout
se rencontrer en montagne, en forêt, ou encore
dans des marais ou des zones inondables, c'est
sympa.
On en trouvait aussi sur des îles, comme
l'île de Lérins qui devient ensuite, je
vous le donne en mille...
-Un monastère.
-Mais aussi dans des anciennes villas gallo-romaines
abandonnées, des bâtiments en ruines, des
grottes...
Ils ne sont pas forcément loin de tout, ni
dans des lieux où l'homme n'a jamais mis
les pieds: leur idée est de s'isoler spirituellement,
de préférence hors des chemins mais pas
forcément loin des hommes en terme de kilomètres.
Et puis, aspect pratique, ils s'installent
de préférence près d'une source ou d'un
ruisseau, et emmènent quand même avec eux
un minimum de vaisselle et des livres.
-Certains entretiennent même des ruches.
Leur quotidien n'est pas confortable pour
autant, c'est pas le but.
Ils ont une alimentation sobre, faite de cueillette,
beaucoup meurent d'accidents, de maladies
ou de froid.
J'aime particulièrement le témoignage de
Vulfilaicus, ou Saint Wulphy pour les intimes,
dont le froid faisait tomber les ongles de
ses pieds et formait des stalactites dans
sa barbe.
Dès le Ve siècle en Occident nos petits
ermites disséminés ici et là se transforment
en communautés cénobites puis en monastères.
Au IVe siècle les premières règles sont
rédigées pour codifier leur mode de vie,
d'abord en Orient, puis l'Occident s'y met
aussi.
Il y en a une rédigée par Saint Pacôme,
par Jean Cassien...
-La plus connue est écrite par Benoît de
Nursie au début du VIe siècle, mais on en
reparlera dans la suite de l'histoire.
L'idée de ces règles, surtout en occident,
est aussi de faire rentrer les moines dans
le cadre de l’Église parce que jusque là
ils ont surtout fait leurs histoires dans
leur coin et ça plaît pas trop aux évêques
qui sont assez partagés:
-Gnngnngnn, je me retire du monde parce que
ma foi est plus pure
-Quelle beauté dans cette manière de vivre,
quel exemple à suivre!
-Pour Grégoire le Grand, qui fonde lui-même
quelques monastères, les moines ne sont pas
forcément des gens à la recherche de Dieu
mais souvent des hommes à la recherche de
tranquillité dans ce monde cruel et violent.
-ET DES FEMMES!
-Évidemment, mais on fera une partie rien
que pour elles vu qu'elles sont quand même
un peu à part dans le domaine de l’Église.
-Sans blague.
-Bref, les règles monastiques s'imposent,
chaque monastère adoptant ses regula sur
la part laissée au travail, à la culture,
à la prière, le rythme de la journée, la
discipline etc.
Nous arrivons ainsi au VIe siècle, où il
y a déjà près de 200 monastères en Gaule.
A cette époque et durant tout le Haut MA
la plupart des moines restent des laïcs,
ils n'ont pas de formation religieuse et on
trouve souvent seulement un ou deux prêtres
parmi eux.
-Pour qu'une abbaye soit fondée, il faut
donc au moins un gars qui s'y connaissent
et qui puisse apprendre la liturgie aux autres:
les abbayes sont aussi des centres de formation
à la vie monastique.
-Une nouveauté apparaît cependant au VIe
siècle: des aristocrates et souverains
commencent à patronner des fondations monastiques,
en donnant l'argent, le terrain ou les deux.
Les rois Sigismond, Childebert Ier, ou les
reines Brunehaut et Radegonde fondent des
monastères même si la majorité reste à
l'initiative d'évêques ou de religieux.
L'idée est d'étaler sa générosité, et
éventuellement d'avoir un coin tranquille
où prendre sa retraite à la fin de sa vie.
Le monachisme n'est donc plus vu comme un
arrachement à la société, et il commence
à remplir un rôle social important:
-Les moines prient pour le salut de l'âme
de tous
-Surtout pour ceux qui ont payé le monastère
-Et tout le monde sera sauvé, veni vidi vici.
-Ils peuvent remplir quelques autres rôles
comme éduquer des enfants de la famille,
placer ceux qu'on n'arrive pas à marier,
les vieux, et servir de lieu de mémoire pour
les ancêtres.
-Un autre intérêt est de doter les territoires
d'une meilleure organisation administrative,
via les monastères.
Classique.
-Parfois aussi les raisons de la fondation
du monastère sont le bonheur, pour fêter
la naissance d'un héritier par exemple, ou
le regret: l'abbaye de Gevelsberg, à vos
souhaits est fondée par le comte Frédéric
d'Isenberg sur le site où il a assassiné
l'archevêque de Cologne.
Son oncle.
-Pardooon.
-Ces monastères restent attachés et en grande
partie sous le contrôle de la famille qui
les a fondés, les autres monastères classiques
sont sous la responsabilité de l'évêque
mais commencent à demander des privilèges
et plus d'autonomie au VIIe siècle.
-Abbaye de Saint Gall indépendante!
-A la fin du VIe siècle, de nouveaux moines
arrivent dans le game: ils sont instruits.
Ils sont intellectuels.
Ils respectent une ascèse stricte.
Les IRLANDAIS.
Tout commence par Saint Colomban, encore un
aristocrate devenu moine au monastère de
Bangor.
Après trente ans de prières et d'autre trucs
de moine, il demande l'autorisation à son
abbé pour partir sur le continent avec douze
copains et exporter les coutumes irlandaises
partout où il passe.
Non, pas celles là.
Il se rend à la cour mérovingienne, burgonde,
et traverse ainsi la Gaule pendant 25 ans
en fondant au passage différents monastères
comme celui de Luxeuil ou de Bobbio, où il
s'installe et meurt en 615.
A sa mort, l'abbé de Bobbio envoie un de
ses moines faire le chemin inverse vers l'Irlande
pour se renseigner sur la vie de Colomban
et écrire sa biographie, qui devient un best-seller.
Son action et celle de ses disciples permet
la fondation de 250 à 300 monastères et
l'établissement pour la première fois d'un
groupe de monastères régis par les mêmes
règles: ils respectent tous le modèle
irlandais basé sur une forte discipline et
l'importance de l'ascèse.
Cette idée de monastères unifiés selon
les mêmes règles fait son chemin au VIIe
siècle.
Jusque là c'était le fondateur du monastère
qui écrivait les règles, en se basant sur
les premières règles de saint Augustin et
compagnie mais en les remaniant à sa sauce.
Les règles exposaient le code de vie religieuse
de l'abbaye, l'organisation de la vie quotidienne,
les relations avec le monde extérieur, et
étaient complétées par des coutumes et
des statuts qui précisaient l'organisation
matérielle de l'abbaye.
Il existait donc une trentaine de communautés
différentes jusqu'à ce que Saint-Benoît
réapparaisse dans l'histoire.
-J'ai déjà parlé rapidement de Benoît
de Nursie en début de vidéo: il faisait
partie d'une famille sénatoriale italienne
mais quitte tout pour devenir ermite puis
fonder quelques monastères.
-Au début du VIe siècle, il termine ses
jours au Mont Cassin et rédige la règle
bénédictine, une règle assez courte qui
prône une division de la vie des moines en
trois temps: la méditation et prière individuelle,
-Lectio Divina,
-Le temps de prière collective,
-Opus Dei,
-Et le travail manuel.
-Je ne connais pas ce mot là.
-Sans blague.
-Il met aussi en avant le rôle de l'abbé,
qui doit être choisi par les moines et l'importance
d'apprendre à lire, ce qui montre que beaucoup
de moines à son époque entraient encore
au monastère analphabètes.
Cela nécessite la dota tion en bibliothèque,
école et scriptorium qui font des monastères
bénédictins des lieux de culture.
Le dernier point important est la stabilité
du moine qui doit rester toute sa vie dans
le monastère, contrairement aux irlandais
qui aimaient parcourir les routes pour aller
vendre du rêve ailleurs.
Sa règle n'a pas un retentissement immédiat,
jusqu'à ce que le pape Grégoire le Grand
rédige une biographie de saint Benoît au
début du VIIe siècle.
A partir de là et sous l'influence du pape
et des carolingiens, la règle bénédictine
se répand partout.
-Ce qui donne les monastères bénédictins!
-Grégoire le Grand est aussi celui qui évangélise
l'Angleterre et y impose cette règle.
Les carolingiens adorent cette règle.
Charlemagne fait de la fondation de monastères
un privilège royal, et en 816 la règle bénédictine
est imposée pour tous.
Charlemagne puis Louis le Pieux nomment eux-même
les abbés des monastères royaux, souvent
des laïcs de leur famille, ce qui leur vaut
parfois quelques mécontentements de la part
des moines.
Sous les carolingiens, le nombre de monastères
passe de 200 au début du VIIe siècle à
plus de 600 au début du IXe.
Le recrutement se fait soit par vocation soit
par don d'un enfant au monastère, qu'on appelle
oblation, et cette très forte expansion des
monastères entraîne la formation de villes
autour des monastères.
-La ville de Saint-Riquier, par exemple, se
forme autour d'une abbaye de 300 moines et
compte 7000 habitants ce qui est assez balèze
pour l'époque.
-Cette belle expansion qui nous montre que
même le Haut Moyen Âge n'était pas un temps
obscur, merci bien, est toutefois freinée
par les destructions hongroises, sarrasines
et normandes.
Le pouvoir central décline à cause des invasions,
le rôle des évêques aussi, et jusqu'au
Xe siècle l'humeur n'est plus vraiment à
la fondation de monastères mais à la sauvegarde
des meubles.
Les monastères existants conservent leur
rôle de formation culturelle et d'administration
du territoire, mais c'est tout.
Puisque cette première partie était déjà
bien longue et pleine d'informations passionnantes,
les moines du Xe au XVe siècle feront l'objet
d'une autre vidéo où c'est pas pour vous
teaser mais on verra le retour des ermites,
de nouvelles organisations plus rayonnantes
que jamais, des ordres mendiants au bord de
l'hérésie et...
-Et les femmes?
-Ah mais oui, tiens, avant de conclure:
parlons des femmes.
Bizarrement j'ai trouvé moins d'informations
sur les femmes que sur les hommes, donc ça
va aller plutôt vite.
Même si les premiers moines sont des hommes,
les femmes sont rapidement attirées par l'idée
de se consacrer à la religion mais les modalités
sont un peu différentes.
Elles font vœu de virginité et passent leur
vie recluse chez elles à lire la Bible toute
la journée et s'occuper des pauvres de temps
en temps.
Dès le IVe siècle, des évêques reconnaissent
leur engagement en les consacrant comme épouses
du Christ.
Elles sont alors autorisées à porter un
voile comme les femmes mariée.
Certaines chrétiennes fondent aussi des monastères
familiaux en invitant toutes les jeunes filles
et veuves qui veulent les rejoindre pour vivre
recluses ensemble.
Des communautés féminines apparaissent au
VIe siècle, les premiers monastères féminins
qui adoptent des règles féminines.
-Eh t'façon les règles c'est féminin.
-Non mais oh!
Il existe différents types de monastères
féminins: des abbayes indépendantes sous
la tutelle de l'évêque, des monastères
qui sont des branches féminines des ordres
masculins qui existent déjà ou des monastères
doubles comme Fontevraud qui a deux branches
en gros.
Les moines d'un côté, les moniales de l'autre.
Les monastères féminins sont quand même
moins nombreux.
Cluny, qu'on abordera surtout la prochaine
fois, compte 880 monastères dont 20 pour
les femmes.
La règle bénédictine spécial femmes est
rédigée en 817 et réduit les contacts avec
l'extérieur au minimum, même l'abbesse ne
peut se déplacer qu'avec l'autorisation de
l'évêque.
Les monastères féminins plaisent à l'aristocratie
qui fait des dons, des cadeaux, parce que
comme ça s'ils savent pas quoi faire de leurs
filles ou de leurs veuves, y'aura toujours
une place pour elles.
Par contre ces monastères ne sont pas exclusivement
féminins parce que les femmes savent pas
tout faire non plus: il y a des prêtres
pour assurer l'office, des sergents pour la
sécurité, un prévôt pour rendre la justice
sur le territoire de l'abbaye...
Tout ça, elles savent pas faire.
Le seul ordre vraiment fondé par des femmes
est l'ordre des brigittines, qui apparaît
au XIVe siècle.
Sacrée Brigitte.
Enfin au XIIe siècle apparaissent les béguines
surtout dans les villes du Nord, qui sont
à la base des femmes se rapprochant des pratiques
religieuses du IVe siècle: elles mènent
un mode de vie ascétique et pratiquent la
charité tout en continuant de vivre chez
elles, tranquille...
-Je les comprends tout à fait !
-Et ça ne plaît pas trop à l’Église
qui du coup n'a aucun contrôle sur elles.
Certaines finissent par fonder des monastères,
d'autres sont brûlées pour hérésies.
En 1311 le béguinage est interdit par le
Pape mais l'interdiction est levée par la
suite.
Du coup et puisqu'il reste énormément de
choses à dire sur les moines durant le Bas
Moyen Âge, Xe-XVe si vous n'êtes pas trop
à l'aise avec les termes techniques, on va
s'arrêter ici.
Dans le prochain épisode on parlera des nouveaux
ordres qui apparaissent durant cette période,
je vous ai déjà spoilé Cluny, et aussi
un peu plus de l'organisation de la vie monacale:
comment ils vivaient, ce qu'ils faisaient
de leurs journées, pourquoi dans les films
ils passent leur temps à recopier des livres
en faisant des coloriages, etc.
Avant de vous quitter je tiens aussi à rappeler
comme j'y pense pas souvent que j'ai deux
plateformes sur lesquelles vous pouvez faire
des dons pour me permettre, projet fou, de
vivre de cette chaîne un jour:
Tipeee, qui est plutôt connu, vous pouvez
faire des dons mensuels ou ponctuels, classique.
Ou Utip, plus récent, très sympa aussi,
même principe sauf que vous pouvez aussi
choisir de regarder des pubs gratos et ça
me rapporte de l'argent.
Voilà.
-Sinon elle nous nourrit pas.
-Je vous dis donc à dans trois semaines pour
la deuxième partie, au revoir.